[Music]  Darla's I like dumb I like strutting I  like Sean it looks like car TV also  likes to break records I'm so excited I  cannot believe that I like it his number  one after car D became the first female  rapper to have two number-one hits on  the Billboard Hot 100 lists the pregnant  star celebrated by what else twerking  she landed the top two singles on the  charts thanks to her first hit 2017  spodek yellow I don't dance now I make  money moves and her Spanglish track I  like it featuring J Balvin 25 year old  took to Instagram to thank her fans for  helping her reach the unexpected music  milestone I always loved this record but  I ain't no friend I slept on it and I  slept on this record because you know  two verses on this song J Balvin and bad  bunny parties in Spanish and I figure  not all my fans know Spanish but it's  like there's a song y'all made it happen  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]